Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
They just dropped a brand new Invincible Season
2 Episode 5 Trailer video
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
according to the trailer will be getting new episodes
starting March 14th.
it'll be the rest of the four episodes for season two.
Like each season is eight episodes.
they haven't completely revealed
when season three is supposed to be released.
But Robert Kirkman made it sound like
there would be less breaks between seasons.
So it is possible that we get season three either
at the very end of this year or like early next year.
so no more waiting like two years between seasons.
but the teaser basically picks up in the immediate
aftermath of the battle
with the Viltrumites on Thraxa.
Everything is still on fire.
General Craig seems like he's already left
with Omni-Man and gone back to the doldrums,
his home planet.
And they're putting him in their super max jet
like a Viltrumites prison
with all their other really powerful beings
they've captured and have sentenced to death.
that's one of the twists of
Viltrumites prison is basically just
a holding cell while they're waiting to execute people.
and battle beast who is also captured.
So for those of you wanting
battle bees to come back into the story,
he will eventually come back
basically what happens here with Invincible
is that he returns to Earth with Oliver
like Omni-Man asked him to his son with Andriese.
he eventually winds up going by the name
kid Omni-Man in the comics
think is a superhero name that he chooses for himself.
And just like Mark's DNA, the viltrumite
Half of his DNA is so powerful,
that even though he's born half thraxan
and he looks kind of purple here,
the viltrumite half of him essentially overpowers
his body and eventually he can become just as powerful
as a normal viltrumite
they're couple exceptions to that.
Like his lifespan is a little bit shorter than say
like Mark's life span
because humans live much longer than three axons.
but you can see here as he gets older eventually
he looks totally viltrumite like you don't see
any hint of coloration from the three axons on his skin
but part of the idea is that he matures way faster.
So he's going to grow to adulthood,
come into his powers way faster than Mark did.
but essentially the same situation with Mark
and the whole cross-breeding like half human
half built from his human half
made it take longer for his powers to manifest.
But eventually given more time, his built from
it DNA will basically take over his body completely
so that he'll be more like a full build from I
he can go on to become the most powerful Viltrumite
who's ever lived because they are able
to keep getting stronger the longer they live,
the longer they train their bodies.
Like if they could just keep getting more
and more powerful,
it'd be kind of like a bodybuilder in real life,
like Arnold Schwarzenegger if he lived forever
and could just make his muscles stronger
and stronger with more and more training.
I guess you could say theoretically
there is another person out there in the comics
who could become more powerful than Mark
because of some extra powers they get as a result
of some subsequent crossbreeding between races, the way
their powers all interact and combine.
But you can't really talk about that
without getting into spoilers
because it's like way further off in the comics.
a big part of the storyline for Oliver
initially in the second half of season
two is Mark taking him home and Debbie
getting used to him,
but she eventually treats him like a surrogate mother
and Mark treats him like a regular little brother.
so he basically becomes
just another regular member of their family on earth
while Omni-Man is stuck in the Viltrumite prison.
generally, it's pretty positive
between the three of them on earth.
he continues to grow super fast coming into his powers,
but Mark has a lot of moments with him that are
references to things that omni-man did with him
when he was a child and then developed his powers.
So basically, is Mark trying to use
all the lessons that Omni-Man taught him
before he revealed his secret in?
Everything went completely nuts
at the end of season one.
impart of the idea
is that eventually Oliver becomes powerful enough
to start becoming a superhero in his own right.
Using powers to help people fight villains eventually
fight the Viltrumites with Omni-Man everyone else.
they kind of tease that in the first half of season
two, particularly with the Coalition
of Planets storyline in Status
like he was thinking about,
now we have two extra vulture mites
who can help fight the other Viltrumites.
But he didn't know about Oliver yet, which means three
more vulture mites to fight the other vulture mites?
Speaking of which,
there was the teaser for Alan the alien returning.
They only hinted at they.
This is true origin story,
whether they made it seem like he was super shady,
that's not exactly what was going on.
It was a bit of a misdirect.
I don't want to get too far into his backstory
because that kind of gets into spoilers.
But his scene at the end of the first
half of the season was a teaser
for Alan's return
and him becoming way more powerful part of the idea.
And they kind of tease this with his origin story
and how he was modified to become the strongest member
of their race.
one of the quirks of his creation
is that he grows stronger with damage that he takes.
So the village demise basically almost wound up
killing him like he's on the edge of death here.
part of the ideas that Thetas wants to trigger
his regeneration and process,
where his body will basically come back
and be even stronger.
So he'll get more and more powerful,
the bigger beatings that he takes.
one of the other biggest teasers
that they'll be paying off
is Omni-Man telling Invincible about reading his books.
Read my works part of the idea is that
all of his books are actually based on real life
things that happened to him in his adventures
before he came to Earth.
all of his books are meant to be stories about beings
who are capable of either
killing or fighting the Viltrumites.
earlier in his life, when he was just working under
the rag as part of the normal viltrumite military,
he was ordered to go around and take out threats
that could potentially take down the Viltrumites
so eventually when he came to Earth
and he needed that day job, he wrote stories
based on all these different beings
that he encountered.
the man with the invincible.
Gun is meant to be about the space race or a character
that he encountered in an earlier mission.
He's meant to be a parody of Lobo in the DC Comics.
But he also has a gun that operates a little bit
like Thor's Hammer.
His gun fires invincible blast
that can shoot through anything.
They can even kill Viltrumites and the gun
can only be fired by him.
So if someone tried to steal the gun,
it would just come right back to his hand.
Kind of like Thor's hammer returns to his hand
when he calls it
And just like Thor's hammer, usually only Thor
or only the worthy can actually pick it up.
in the case of space racer only he can pick it up.
So part of the idea is that
Omni-Man is telling Invincible to read his books
and go find those people
and use them to help fight the vulture mites.
one of the other books here, Savage Planet
Savage Bees is a reference to the Ragnar's
Runners are these really giant alien bees kind of like
alien dinosaurs capable of injuring and killing
built from the gravity on their planet is also so dense
that they've evolved to be just extremely tough.
And that's why they can fight them.
they're meant to be one of the few races,
one of the few planets that the Viltrumites
could not conquer.
there's also the Clark's plants, which are basically
plants that are deadly enough to kill those Viltrumites.
And you have battle bees raised, too, in the idea
of battle bees coming back into the story.
Remember, he's also inside that village from a prison.
Eventually, Omni-Man teams up with Alan,
the alien in battle bees to escape that prison.
Maybe they'll say that for season three,
there could be a season two moment.
Probably One of the other biggest teasers
that they'll pay off is Angstrom
Levy coming after Invincible again for revenge.
They moved around some of the comic book plot
a little bit, so some stuff happened way sooner
that did in the comics.
Some stuff has been delayed a little bit,
but I think they're trying to end season two on a bang
with a really huge fight
between Angstrom Levy in Invincible from the comics
eventually he comes after invincibles
mother and Oliver.
They battle it out, but it's not the last fight
they ever have because they also eventually
pay off a big teaser that Angstrom Levy dropped
at the beginning of season two.
this is also meant to pay off the introduction,
like the very first opening scene of season two.
so remember they picked up in that alternate universe
with the evil version of Invincible
who sided with Omni-Man
and try to take over the planet.
Later we revisit that place at the end of season two
in Ekstrom, Levi tries to get more information
about how they were actually able to capture him.
Like, how did they actually wind up getting you?
he's hoping to use that information to benefit him
in taking down Invincible in the main universe
and before his accident before Engstrom
live turned evil, he was telling the Muellers
about all the different universes
and the different versions of Invincible
that he'd encountered, and said that this main version
was unique in that he actually turned
good against his father, against the evil Viltrumites in
in most other universes.
Invincible, always almost always turned evil.
so remember that scene where he pulled a bunch of the
mullahs from different universes to fight invincible?
Eventually he does the same thing
with a bunch of evil versions
of Invincible,
turning them on the main universe version
invincible has been training his powers up
like he's slowly getting more and more powerful.
But part of the idea is the beginning of season two.
all those different Mueller's, who by themselves aren't
more powerful than him, were able to overpower him.
Imagine what that would be like
if a bunch of other versions of Invincible
were fighting him at the same time.
so we might see a version of that
at the end of season two with him
just fighting a bunch of alternate universe
versions of himself who are all evil.
in probably one of the other biggest changes
I don't know if they're going to save this for season
three is his whole relationship
with Amber and Atom Eve.
So in the comics, one of the big changes
is that he actually kind of moves
past that relationship with Amber
pretty quickly on the show.
I think they prolong that because they just want
to delay his relationship with Atom Eve,
like, okay, we'll save this for season three.
So we'll see how much longer he stays
with the Amber character.
I'm guessing through at least the end of season two
that either might be the end of their relationship
or maybe they'll have broken up by the time season
three begins, or at some point during season three.
there's a whole bunch of stuff
that goes on between Invincible and Atom Eve
but it just sounds like there's so big.
They want to save a lot of that storyline
for a little bit later.
that's mostly why you saw her storyline
being completely separate from Invincible storyline
in the first half of season two.
Like she has all of her own stuff going on that
she's dealing with,
but part of the idea is that they're adding
a lot of storyline that wasn't in the comics
because these are hour long episodes where normally
for animated series you only get half hour episodes.
so these have a lot of extra room
to fill out these storylines
for different characters that normally wouldn't
have gotten that story in the comics.
we'll probably get a bigger trailer for Invincible
Season two Episode five in a couple of weeks.
Of course, I'll do more videos as we get more footage.
There was a bunch of stuff that dropped today,
a bunch of teasers, bunch of trailer
for stuff coming this week.
I'll try to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
There's a brand new Avatar, The Last Airbender
Netflix trailer that's coming tomorrow
There should be up on my channel
pretty early in the morning.
There are a couple. Marvel
What if teasers that they drop.
So I'll try to do videos for all that stuff
in the next couple of days.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything
click here for that brand new Avatar
The Last Airbender trailer, and click here
for all my Invincible episodes.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!